[Musik]
wer links konservativ bislang für einen
unrealistischen Widerspruch gehalten hat
soll durch sie eines Besseren belehrt
werden dabei gilt SAR wagenkncht selber
vielen schon als ein wandelnder
Widerspruch viele sagen sie ist eine
Hoffnungsträgerin viele sagen sie ist
eine Gefahr und einige sagen auch sie
ist ein Mysterium fakt ist jedenfalls
dass sie die deutsche Parteienlandschaft
gründlich durcheinander gewirbelt hat
SAR wagen herzlich Willkommen zu phöniix
persönlich hallo ich grüß sie Frau WN
wir sind hier in einem Hotel in der
Oderberger Straße sie sind hier
aufgewachsen in dieser Straße und
erzählen gerne die Geschichte wie sie
als kleines Mädchen den Touristen die
sie von der Westseite von Berlin über
die Mauer hin angeschaut haben von einer
Aussichtsplattform aus die Zunge
rausgestreckt haben wie viel von diesem
wehrhaften kleinen Mädchen steckt heute
noch in ihnen na ja also es war schon so
dass wir uns damals als Kinder geärgert
haben es gab ja wirklich so
Aussichtsplattform wo die drüber geguckt
haben und wir fühlten uns so wie im Zoo
so beobachtet ne also was sind das da
für komische Kinder in so einer
abgefragten Straße die sah ja damals
völlig anders aus ganz grau die Häuser
waren noch quasi mit Kriegs versehrten
Löchern und ähnlichem also ich glaube
schon dass ich jemand bin der auch sehr
ja
überzeugt die Dinge vertritt die ich für
richtig halte und sich davon auch nicht
abbringen lässt ich glaube das ist aber
in der Politik auch wichtig wenn mich
jemand von was anderem überzeugt dann
sehr gerne aber ich würde nicht weil
Menschen um mich herum oder eine Gruppe
oder auch eine Partei jetzt etwas sagt
was anders ist als das was ich meine
plötzlich meine Meinung verändern auch
wenn ich nicht das für richtig halten
würde ich glaube das sollte man auch nie
tun sie sagen sie haben sich beobachtet
gefühlt daran hat sich nicht viel
geändert würde ich sagen auch heute sind
sie sehr unter Beobachtung und haben vor
einigen Wochen den Verein Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht gegründet der in eine
Parteigründung Anfang Januar münden soll
äh nehmen Sie uns doch mal mit wie
laufen da die Vorbereitungen gerade ja
es ist ganz schön anstrengend also es
ist ja schon so wie in vielen Bereichen
sind in Deutschland die Vorschriften und
die Gesetze relativ komplex auch eine
Vereins aber erst recht eine
Parteigründung da ist viel zu beachten
was die Satzung angeht man braucht
Geschäftsordnungen und alles mögliche
schiedsordnungen also Dinge mit denen
ich mich im Leben nie beschäftigt habe
die aber alle stimmen müssen weil wir
das ja dann alles einreichen müssen wenn
wir die Partei gründen und wenn da
irgendein Fehler drin ist dann würde uns
das massiv schädigen weil wir dann ja
natürlich jetzt nicht wir müssen ja im
Januar schon die Europaliste aufstellen
und wenn uns da etwas unterlaufen würde
wäre es ein Problem also auch wir
beschäftigen Anwälte um damit Zande zu
kommen aber ich glaube wir sind auf dem
guten Weg und vor allem und das ist für
mich vor allem wichtig ich spüre ganz
viel Zuspruch also mir schreiben
Menschen ich werde auf der Straße
angesprochen und ganz viele sagen das
ist jetzt so notwendig dass diese neue
Partei entsteht und das ermutigt
natürlich sehr in der in der Debatte ist
vor allen Dingen im Moment die Frage wie
sie diese Partei dann finanzieren im
Moment generieren Sie spenden über den
Verein lassen wir jetzt mal diese ganzen
Formalia beiseite eigentlich
entscheidend ist doch nur die Frage
beziehen sie Geld oder haben sie Spenden
bekommen aus Russland können Sie das
Ausschließen also unser Schatzmeister
hat nachgeguckt und es gibt exakt 75 €
wo irgendwie eine russische Kennung da
sichtbar ist natürlich bekommen wir kein
Geld aus Russland sondern wir bekommen
Geld von Bürgerin und Bürgern
überwiegend deutschen also auch die die
aus dem EU-Ausland Spenden oder auch wir
haben ja aus den USA Spenden nach den
Namen zu urteilen das sind natürlich
überwiegend deutsche Bürger und Bürger
die im Ausland leben die das Geschehen
hier verfolgen und die uns unterstützen
wollen und der ist allergrößte Teil der
Spenden also die auslandsspenden sind ja
nur also nicht EU-Ausland 1,5% unsereer
gesamtspenden die meisten Spenden kommen
hier von Menschen auch mit kleinem
geldbeudel das sieht man an den Beträgen
also wir haben eigentlich in erster
Linie Kleinspenden aber eben sehr seh
sehr viele davon also Menschen die 5 €
10 € 20 € Spenden da merkt man die
müssen auch wirklich rechnen aber sie
wollen trotzdem uns unterstützen und das
finde ich so beeindruckend und da bin
ich wirklich sehr sehr dankbar was
machen Sie jetzt mit den 75 € mit der
russischen Kennung oh Gott ich weiß es
nicht also ich ich gehe mal davon aus
dass der Schatzmeister weiß was man
regulär damit macht aber ich glaube
nicht dass uns irgendeiner unterstellen
kann dass wir uns davon korrumpieren
lassen also wie gesagt aus den USA sind
glaube ich gut 1000 € gekommen deswegen
sind wir jetzt keine beiden Fans und 75
€ machen uns garantiert nicht zu Putin
Fans zumal das ja auch nicht also sag
mal die kam ja auch nicht aus dem
Kremmel also ich finde ein bisschen
wirklich das zeigt auch wie wie Debatten
in Deutschland laufen also statt jetzt
darüber zu reden was wir wollen wo wir
hin wollen haben gab es sichich Artikel
darüber dass wir jetzt also auch Spenden
aus dem Ausland empfangen und das wurde
skandalisiert als sei das jetzt etwas
ganz phänomenales was keine andere
Partei macht das ist natürlich Unsinn
also wir haben uns ja exakt an das
Parteienrecht gehalten und das besagt
man darf also nur Spenden aus dem
Ausland erhalten unter 1000 € wenn etwas
größere gekommen wäre meines Wissens ist
das nicht der Fall hätten wir es
zurücküberwiesen und inoweit glaube ich
natürlich bekommen auch andere Parteien
sicherlich Spenden von Auslandsdeutschen
die sie dort unterstützen bei den
anderen Parteien ist viel mehr das
Problem dass sie eben auch Großspenden
bekommen von Rüstungsunternehmen von
Finanzunternehmen und da geht es um
Summen die wirklich Politik beeinflussen
und ich finde das ist eher und sollte
eher ein Thema sein wobei sie die
Spenden von Finanzunternehmen im
Zweifelsfall ja sicherlich auch gerne
annehmen wden Frau Wagenknecht geh ich
ich glaube es ist aber kein Zufall dass
wir sie nicht bekommen und ich sage ihn
auch ganz sicher voraus wir werden auch
von keinem einzigen Rüstungskonzern
irgendeinen müden Euro bekommen weil
logischerweise wir natürlich eine
Politik machen die deren Interessen
jetzt nicht unbedingt entgegenkommt und
ich wünschte mir wir hätten auch eine
Bundesregierung die stärker unabhängige
Politik macht also geht's ja nicht nur
um Spenden sondern der Lobby Ismus der
Einfluss von sehr starken Lobbys auf die
Politik und die macht auch politische
Entscheidung zu beeinflussen das ist ja
extrem in Deutschland man sieht das eben
an den ganzen Entscheidungen also warum
wird warum macht die Ampel jetzt eine
Politik die wieder den
onormalverbraucher den Normalbürger
belastet aber traut sich nicht an die
Dinge ranzugehen wo wirklich abgesahn
wird also die ganze Rüstungs die
Rüstungsausgaben sind extrem
intransparent da gehen Milliarden
Aufträge über den Tresen ohne dass es
seriöse Verträge gibt ohne dass es eine
ernsthafte Preisverhandlung gibt ohne
dass es eine wirkliche Ausschreibung
gibt also jede Kommune muss alles
ausschreiben am besten europaweit da
geht's um Milliarden das ist da sind
wirklich richtig Selbstbedienungsläden
auch in anderen Bereichen gibt's das und
ich finde wir brauchen wirklich eine
Politik die sich unabhängig macht von
solchen einflussreichen Lobbys damit
wieder Politik für die Bürger und Bürger
gemacht werden kann lassen Sie uns über
die Inhalte sprechen wir natürlich
gleich noch aber lassen Sie uns noch mal
kurz bei der Parteien Gründung bleiben
weil das ja doch äh eine eher seltene
Geschichte ist in Deutschland würde ich
mal sagen in den letzten Jahrzehnten sie
haben ihrem Verein äh den Namen Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht gegeben
ähm locker gesprochen ich glaube das hat
sich ja offenbar nicht mal Silvio
berdoskoni getraut ähm warum haben Sie
das gemacht also wirklich aus rein
pragmatischen Gründen also ich brauche
das nicht für mein Ego dass eine Partei
nach mir heißt und es sie soll auch
nicht auf Dauer so heißen also natürlich
muss der parteiname irgendwann
unabhängig von meinem Namen werden das
ist völliger Konsens ich will ja auch
nicht für die nächsten 30 Jahre noch
Politik machen und die Partei soll sich
ja schon das ist ja der Anspruch im
Parteienspektrum verankern s dass sie
auch in 20 30 40 Jahren noch da ist aber
es ist natürlich schon schwer und in
Deutschland besonders eine eine neue
Partei zu gründen deswegen ist es ja
auch nicht oft gelungen und da hat man
natürlich z.B mit solchen
Herausforderungen zu kämpfen man steht
im Wahlzettel ganz weit unten die Leute
müssen einen finden wir haben bei der
Bundestagswahl die Regelung das ist in
den meisten Ländern an anders aber in
Deutschland ist es so wir haben
Landeslisten das heißt zur
Bundestagswahl werde ich zwar
Spitzenkandidatin der Partei sein aber
ich werde nur in einem einzigigen
Bundesland persönlich auf dem Wahlzettel
stehen in allen anderen als Kandidatin
nicht die Menschen müssen aber trotzdem
wissen was ist jetzt die
wagenknechtpartei weil natürlich werden
Parteien mit Personen verbunden also das
ist ja auch klar man hat ja gar nicht so
viel Möglichkeiten sich politisch zu
profilieren wenn man jemand wenn jemand
bekannt ist dann wissen die Leute
zunächsten mal da will der hin und und
das ist ja für wählerinen und Wähler
wichtig und ich glaube mit mir verbindet
man natürlich auch bestimmte Inhalte
bestimmte Positionen und dafür steht die
Partei und das wollen wir jetzt mit
diesem vorläufigen Namen natürlich auch
zum Ausdruck bringen sie gehen mit das
Stichwort vorläufig sie haben gerade
selber mit der Bundestagswahl
argumentiert heißt das dass die Partei
ihren Namen auch tragen wird die Partei
wird bis zur Bundestagswahl diesen Namen
tragen wir werden allerdings ein zweiten
Teil des parteinamens beschließen und
dann nach der Bundestagswahl spätestens
wird dann mein Name dort nicht mehr
notwendig sein dann lassen Sie uns noch
mal zu der inhaltlichen Ausprägung
kommen also wie müssen wir uns das
vorstellen sie haben ja eine ganze Menge
Gründungsmitglieder offenbar inzwischen
affiriert sitzen sie jetzt alle an einem
Tisch und deklinieren die Themenfelder
durch und wenn gestritten wird da kommen
sie ja nun gerade her aus einer Partei
wo J eine andere Meinung hatte und die
auch
äußerte wenn gestritten wird und Sie
können sich nicht einigen dann heißt es
frag SAR und dann geben Sie vor wie die
Position ist zu dem Feld na wir haben
schon bisschen mehr Mitstreiter
inzwischen als an einen Tisch passen
aber es ist ja wir haben ja z.B als
Verein ein gründungsmanifest da steht
drin das ist zwar noch relativ allgemein
aber es steht doch drin wohin wir wollen
also wir wollen eine Partei sein für
wirtschaftliche Vernunft die die
wirtschaftlichen Stärken vor allem auch
den industriellen Mittelstand in
Deutschland die die Rahmenbedingung
dafür verbessert und nicht die
Unternehmen aus dem Land treibt die für
Handwerker für landwrte tatsächlich auch
ein Umfeld schafft dass sie nicht nur
nur immer mehr unter Druck kommen durch
die Politik sondern endlich mal
Aufblühen wieder und auch bessere
Bedingungen haben hier zu wirtschaften
wir wollen soziale Gerechtigkeit das
halte ich für ganz wichtig das ist ja
wirklich etwas das in den letzten Jahren
immer mehr unter die Räder gekommen ist
also eine Gesellschaft die so
auseinander driftet wie unsere die einen
Erben riesige Vermögen so dass sie im
Grunde ohne irgendwas zu leisten
millioneneinkommen beziehen können und
bei den Kindern aus erberen
Verhältnissen ist es ja faktisch so
selbst wenn sie sich sehr anstrengen
haben sie kaum noch echte
Aufstiegschancen sie haben es fängt ja
bei der Bildung schon an S soziale
Gerechtigkeit dann ist natürlich ein
wichtiges anleegen für uns Frieden also
dass Deutschland wieder eine
Außenpolitik macht das war lange Zeit in
der bonreublik aber auch noch nach der
Wiedervereinigung zunächst eine meines
sachens gute Tradition Deutschland hat
versucht zu vermitteln Kompromisse zu
suchen das war die Entspannungspolitik
heute setzen wir immer stärker auf die
militärische Karte wir positionieren uns
sehr einseitig in den Konflikten dieser
Welt und das ist meinesachtens nicht gut
nicht für unser Land aber auch nicht für
die Welt also Deutschland hat ja schon
ein Gewicht wenn wir stärker auf eine
vermittlungslösung setzen würden und das
vierte große Thema das liegt mir auch
persönlich sehr am Herzen ist dass wir
für Meinungsfreiheit streiten und gegen
diese kcelculture die sich immer mehr
ausbreitet also das ist doch wirklich
also wenn schon Thomas gottscheik sagt
er will nicht weitermachen weil er im
Fernsehen nicht mehr das sagen kann was
er zu Hause sagt dann läuft doch etwas
schief also immer mehr Menschen spüren
doch auch es gibt sofort ein Sch Storm
wenn einfach bestimmte Regeln die eine
elitäre Schicht setzt nicht eingehalten
werden wir haben einen sich verengenden
meinungskorridor der Andersdenkende wird
nicht mehr mit Respekt behandelt sondern
wird zu einem schlechten Menschen
gemacht steht sofort unter
rechtsverdacht und diese Art der Debatte
die die schadet uns auch immens am Ende
hilft sie übrigens auch der AFD das
sieht man ja und auch das finde ich
wichtig
so wie es z.B in der coronazeit war es
ja extrem dass Menschen die anders
andere Position haben auch richtig
physisch ausgegrenzt wordurden aus dem
gesellschaftlichen Leben das haben wir
jetzt bei anderen Debatten zwar in
dieser Form nicht aber wir haben schon
eine Ausgrenzung eine ein unter Druck
setzen von anderen Meinungen ein
Konformitätsdruck der glaube ich unserer
Gesellschaft nicht gut tut und das sind
sag mal das ist der grobe Rahmen jeder
der bei uns mitmacht wird ja auch wenn
er dann Mitglied werden möchte
unterschreiben dass er natürlich diese
Zielrichtungen teilt dass er sich auch
abgrenzt von radikalen extremistischen
Positionen dass ist natürlich auch sehr
sehr wichtig und dann werden wir unsere
Programmatik weiterentwickeln aber das
ist erstmal der grobe Fahrplan lass uns
noch mal ganz kurz zurückkommen bevor
wir dann in der Tat innenpolitisch und
außenpolitisch zu ihrer Partei oder zu
Ihren Vorstellungen noch mal kommen zu
dem Thema Meinungsfreiheit wenn jetzt
z.B Markus löder fordert dass Gendern
verboten werden soll in Schulen oder an
Universitäten ist das nicht genauso
umgekehrt auch wieder etwas was die
Meinungsfreiheit einschränkt na also ich
will jetzt nicht Markus Söder
verteidigen aber wenn wenn ich ih
richtig verstanden habe will er nicht
verbieten dass jemand der das persönlich
also ein Student kann Gendern wenn er
das gut findet aber es geht ja darum ob
in den Einrichtungen diese Sprache
gelehrt und auch verlangt wird und es
ist ja tatsächlich so wir haben das
immer wieder auch junge Leute
geschrieben dass an ihrer
Uni arbeiten schlechter bewertet werden
wenn sie nicht Gendern und ich finde das
muss tatsächlich untersagt werden weil
also ich bin auch kein Freund des
Gendern ich finde jeder soll das machen
wenn das gut findet ich finde es es
zerstört unsere Sprache also die
deutsche Sprache kann eine sehr schöne
Sprache sein ich finde wenn man Goethe
liest wenn man Thomas Mann liest dann
dann spürt man das
wenn man heutige öffentliche Debatten
verfolgt spürt man es weniger aber wenn
man dann noch irgendwie diese ganzen
grälichen
genderregeln einhält das ist das ist
keine deutsche Sprache mehr und ich
finde nicht dass wir dadurch irgendwie
etwas in unserer Gesellschaft zum
Vorteil von Minderheiten oder von Frauen
verbessern also wenn wir über
Frauenrechte reden dann sollten wir
darüber reden warum Frauen immer noch
schlechter bezahlt werden warum es immer
noch nicht genug kitterplätze gibt weil
das vor allem zu Lasten von Frauen geht
das sind doch die wichtigen Themen und
nicht ob ich stottere und
also beim Sternchen also das ich halte
das Stottern ja also wollte jetzt
niemand diskriminieren der stottert aber
das ist ja sozusagen das ist ja eine
sprachregel ich weiß nicht was das
gesellschaftlich verbessern soll und es
gibt ja immer mehr solche Regeln das
dann irgendwie Kinder sich nicht mehr
als Indianer vergleiden dürfen und wenn
Politiker Indianer sagt ist er sowieso
schon ein Rassist das sind absurde
Debatten es sind auch abgehobene
Debatten ich meine die meisten Menschen
die im Alltag ihre Probleme haben die
sagen sich doch Leute die über solche
Fragen diskutieren die den muss es schon
sehr gut gehen wenn sie kein anderes
Problem haben lassen uns bei den
Alltagsproblemen der Menschen bleiben es
gibt diese Woche jetzt einen Beschluss
der Ampelkoalition Sparpotenziale
aufgedeckt wurden weil man eben dieses
60 Milliarden Loch im Haushalt hatte wie
wir ich denke jeder weiß wovon wir
sprechen Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und so weiter
nun liegen die Schlüsse so wage auf dem
Tisch
wie bewerten Sie die und natürlich im
zweiten Teil hätten sie die
Schuldenbremse aufgelöst also ich
verstehe nicht wieso herr Scholz und
auch die ganze Regierung ewig mit Herrn
Linder darüber rumgekungelt hat wie man
jetzt irgendwie den Normalbürger
belastet ich hätte es für souveräner
gehalten Herrn Merz in die Pflicht zu
nehmen die CDU Landesfürsten also die
des Ministerpräsidenten auch die
Wirtschaftsminister in vielen Ländern
die wollen und zwar teilweise ja aus
guten Gründen natürlich diese
Förderungen also da geht's ja um
Stahlindustrie da geht's um
wirtschaftsansiedlungen so und diese
Förderung verlangen und das ist ja auch
richtig dass Investitionen anders
behandelt werden als Konsumausgaben des
Staates also natürlich wäre es sinnvoll
die Schuldenbremse so zu reformieren das
sagen auch alle seriösen Ökonomen dass
man Investitionen rausnimmt weil wir
sehen doch also in den USA wird mit
riesigen Subventionen werden dort
tatsächlich auch Zukunftstechnologien
gefördert es wird alles daran gesetzt
dass die Wirtschaft sich dort ansiedelt
das scheint auch einigermaßen zu
funktionieren china macht das ähnlich
und wir hier in Deutschland wir binden
uns die Hände und können nicht mehr
investieren oder auch wirtschaftliche
Investitionen nicht unterstützen ab
abern richtig entschuldig aber wenn ich
richtig gelesen habe sind ja einige
Subventionen rausgenommen worden nein
aber ja aber das Problem ist ja dass
jetzt der Normalbürger mit zusätzlichen
Belastungen dafür bezahlt dass z.B Intel
das ist ja immer in ein hochprofitables
Unternehmen 10 Milliarden bekommt und
das geht nicht sondern das was sinnvoll
gewesen wäre wäre zu sagen okay Herr
März Liebe CDU wenn ihr wollt dass diese
Förderung bleiben und sie sind sinnvoll
dann verhandelt mit uns über eine Reform
also mit der Regierung über eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse weil dafür brauchen
sie ja die CDU das geht ja nur mit zwei
Drittel Mehrheit und es wäre gut gewesen
die Situation jetzt zu nutzen weil die
Schuldenbremse so wie sie jetzt ist die
stranguliert unser Land ich meine wir
haben ja eine Situation wie die
öffentliche Infrastruktur ist marode wir
haben massivste Defizite im
Bildungssystem das hat auch etwas mit
dieser Regel zu tun weil natürlich
gerade dort auch gespart wurde es wurde
über lange Zeit bei Lehrern gespart es
wurde übrigens lange Zeit auch bei
Polizisten gespart also das alles wurde
wurde reduziert die Schuldenbremse hat
leider nie dazu geführt dass man
seriöser mit dem Steuergeld umgegangen
ist sondern man hat in bestimmten
Bereichen reduziert und jetzt merken wir
dass wir einen riesigen Investitionsstau
haben also müssten wir eigentlich per
Kredit Investitionen finanzieren jeder
Unternehmer macht das übrigens per
Kredit also Investitionen kann man per
Kredit finanzieren problematisch wird's
wenn das Unternehmen Dividendenzahlungen
und aktienrückhäufe per Kredit
finanziert also sprich auf den Staat
übertragen wenn seine laufenden Ausgaben
über Schulden laufen dann ist das
natürlich nicht nachhaltig aber
Investitionen in die Zukunft ich meine
was nützt es wenn wir wir unseren Enkeln
und Kindern zwar etwas weniger Schulden
hinterlassen aber dafür eine völlig
marode Infrastruktur ein schlechtes
Bildungssystem Brücken die nicht
funktionieren eine Bahn die nicht mehr
funktioniert also das ist ja auch keine
Lösung und deswegen bedauere ich das wie
es gelaufen ist und ich halte das was
jetzt da herausgekommen ist wirklich für
für absolut inakzeptabel es ist wieder
genau das typische die starken Lobbys
werden wieder bedient
das heizungsgesetz wird natürlich nicht
gekippt obwohl jeder eigentlich weiß
dass das klimapolitischer Unsinn ist es
bleibt dabei über 8 Milliarden Waffen
sollen an die Ukraine fließen die
Rüstungsindustrie freut sich also in
vielen Bereichen wird weiter im Grunde
Geld verschwendet aber gleichzeitig wird
wieder der Normalbürger der sich am
wenigsten wehren kann auch Rentnerinnen
und Rentner Geringverdiener mit
steigenden Heizkosten steigenden
Stromkosten steigenden Spritpreisen
belastet weil das ist ja der Kern dessen
was jetzt beschlossen wurde also es wird
gerade das teurer wo die Menschen
überhaupt nicht ausweichen können und
das wird noch mal Kaufkraft wegziehen
also auch von der konjunkturpolitischen
Seite ist das natürlich der blanke
Wahnsinn wenn man schon in einer
wirtschaftlichen Situation ist wo die
Wirtschaft schrumpft jetzt noch mal so
viel Kaufkraft von den Menschen
abzuziehen heißt ja Sie können eben dann
einmal weniger zum Friseur oder nicht
mehr zum Bäcker und stattdessen bei Aldi
also sie müssen sparen und das ist in
jeder Hinsicht ist sozialungerecht aber
auch ökonomisch genau das Falsche bis zu
dieser Position hätten sie ja ihre
ursprüngliche Partei sage ich jetzt mal
die Linke ja nicht verlassen müssen das
hätte man ja wahrscheinlich mit Ihnen
zusammen unterschrieben ähm wo sie sich
aber doch ganz stark unterscheiden ist
in ihren Vorstellungen zu
Migrationspolitik äh wenn Sie jetzt auf
die neue Partei schauen wenn sie in
aller Kürze mal umreißen könnten was
sind für Sie die essentiellen Punkte was
muss ich ändern in der Migrationspolitik
in Deutschland ja wir müssen die Zahlen
reduzieren also wir haben jetzt in den
letzten Jahren eine derart hohe und vor
allen auch unkontrollierte Zuwanderung
zugelassen dass wir spüren das ist nicht
mehr zu bewältigen und das führt zu
extremen Problemen es führt zu großen
Problemen im Bildungssystem also
natürlich ich habe mit vielen lehrerinen
und Lehrern gesprochen die die in den
Schulen der ärmeren
Wohnbezirke unterrichten also nicht in
den teuren Innenstadtbezirken da ist das
Problem nicht da kommen die Flüchtlinge
nicht hin in den ärmeren in den
brennpunktvierteln die meisten
Schulklassen starten da können weit mehr
als die Hälfte der Kinder kein Wort
Deutsch und dadurch dass jetzt die
Zahlen so hoch sind ist auch die Gefahr
noch mal vergrößert dass
Parallelgesellschaften entstehen weil
auch integr
geht eben nur in einem bestimmten Umfang
und natürlich ist das möglich also ich
finde z.B man kann gucken wie hat
Dänemark das gemacht dänemark hat unter
einer sozialdemokratischen Regierung
massiv die die Zahlen reduziert und der
haupthebel ist dass Menschen die jetzt
nach Dänemark kommen im Grunde wenn sie
keinen Anspruch auf Asyl haben auch
keine Bleibeperspektive haben auch
keinen Anspruch auf soziale Leistung und
ich glaube dass dieses Signal das muss
Deutschland in die Welt senden wir
können nur die aufnehmen die wirklich
asylanspruch haben das sind weniger als
10% von denen die kommen die anderen
werden hier keine Perspektive haben
bisher ist es umgekehrt also jeder der
es irgendwie schafft mittels der
Schleuser nach Deutschland zu kommen der
bleibt im Großen und Ganzen und das ist
natürlich eine enorme sgwirkung und ich
verstehe ja dass Menschen ein besseres
Leben wollen also die die kommen das
sind ja keine bösen Menschen das sind
Menschen die wünschen sich eine bessere
Perspektive aber ich finde man muss
einfach sehen es ist nicht zu schaffen
und und wir sollten auch mal drüber
nachdenken was können wir denn mehr tun
dass in den Heimatländern vielleicht mal
wieder etwas aufblüt also es ist ja kein
Zufall dass viele Menschen jetzt kommen
aus Ländern in denen auch der Westen
Kriege geführt hat Irak ist z.B eines
der fluchtländer oder Syrien ist ein
fluchtland Syrien ist ein Land früher
kam aus Syrien kaum Flüchtlinge weil das
im Nahen Osten eigentlich es war immer
eine Diktatur aber es hatte eine relativ
gute Mittelschicht das hatte für dortige
Verhältnisse eigentlich einen guten
Lebensstandard W das alles kaputt
gemacht word und auch der Wiederaufbau
jetzt findet nicht statt weil es
prachiale Wirtschaftssanktionen gibt
also heben wir die wirtschaftssanktion
auf Krieg Bürgerkrieg ist dort
eigentlich nicht mehr also bis auf ganz
ganz wenige Bereiche das heißt wir
können sehr wohl sagen die Menschen
können zurückkehren sollten auch
zurückgehren wir reden über eine Million
Menschen aus Syrien das sind auch
vielfach Menschen die Syrien eigentlich
braucht das ist nämlich die
Mittelschicht dort hier ist es natürlich
sind die die Qualifikationen oft nicht
anwendbar das ist auch eine großer
Posten im Bürgergeld muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen also sehr wohl ja
ihr könnt nicht mehr hier bleiben aber
wir tun etwas dafür dass in eurer Heimat
wieder etwas aufwärts geht also sprich
wir wir fangen schon mal an damit dass
wir diese Sanktionen aufheben und
vielleicht auch dass die USA nicht
weiter die syrischen Ölfelder besetzt
das ist nämlich auch ein großes Problem
und gibt es aber auch natürlich viele
die Sagen deutschland braucht diese auch
diese Menschen vor allen diese junge
Menschen Deutschland hat steuert auf ein
demografisches Problem zu äh Deutschland
hat ein Fachkräfteproblem wiederum
andere sagen die Hürden sind zu hoch die
kommen viel zu spät in Arbeit wir
erwarten zu viel wir müssen
Leistungsnachweise bringen und so weiter
wä es da nicht auch eine ein ein Weg zu
sagen wir senken unsere Hürden und
bringen so mehr Leute in Arbeit mehr
Leute in Brot und Lohn und haben dadurch
auch weniger Belastung bei Bürgergeld na
ja die Hörden sind ja in dem Sinne also
be Menschen die jetzt längere Zeit hier
sind z.B wenn sie Flüchtlinge aus sen
sind könnten ja arbeiten es ist also
trotzdem sind nur 35%
Sozialversicherungspflicht beschäftigt
das ist ja einfach Objektiv die Realität
da gibt es sie weil wir die Abschüsse
nicht anerkennen weil sie Deutsch weil
aber auch oft nicht kompatibel sind das
ist ja nicht nur eine Frage der
Anerkennung sondern es ist eben nicht
automatisch so wenn man eine bestimmte
Ausbildung in Syrien hat dass man dann
hier in einem Unternehmen in dem Bereich
auch wirklich arbeiten könnte da passt
auch vieles nicht zusammen und sag mal
wieso sollen wir als ein relativ
wohlhabendes Land jetzt eine
Argumentation fahen also wir brauchen
die Fachkräfte aus Syrien also wir wir
sollten lieber mehr dafür tun unsere
unsere eigene jug unsere eigenen
Jugendlichen so auszubilden dass wir
hier Fachkräfte im Land haben also der
jüngste visis Test war ja erschreckend
also wenn man in deutschen Schulen nicht
mehr einigermaßen rechnen lernt wenn man
nicht mehr einigermaßen richtig
schreiben lernt dann entsteht natürlich
eine junge Generation die eigentlich
keine Perspektive hat und wir sollten
alles dafür tun hier wirklich bessere
Bedingung zu schaffen da muss man sich
auch mal angucken was haakt eigentlich
im deutschen Bildungssystem da gibt's ja
viele Dinge über die man da reden muss
die wir gerade auch schon gesprochen
haben entschuldigung dass ich sie
unterbreche wir müssen kurz auch zur
Außenpolitik kommen Frau Wagenknecht sie
schlagen vor die Waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine auszusetzen und schlagen
stattdessen vor dass oder glauben dass
Wladimir Putin dann zu
Friedensverhandlungen bereit wäre was
was gibt ihn dieses Vertrauen in
Wladimir Putin ich vertraue nicht
Wladimir Putin aber ich bin überzeugt
dass ich kriege und gerade so einen
Krieg wie dieser nicht militärisch
beenden lassen sondern nur durch
Verhandlung irgendwann wird dieser Krieg
sowieso durch Verhandlungen beendet
werden weil selbst die ukrainischen
Generäle inzwischen sagen wir können
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen also ja die
sagen wir können den Krieg nicht
gewinnen weil wir nicht genug Waffen
dafür haben und da K man ja auch genau
umgekehrt argumentieren man könte ja
sagen die ukrainischen Generäle sagen
nicht nur weil sie nicht genug Waffen
haben sondern auch weil sie nicht genug
Soldaten haben also das ist ja zurzeit
das was der Ukraine am meisten ausgeht
also wir wir liefern Waffen und wir
liefern immer noch sehr viele Waffen das
ist ja noch nicht das Problem sondern
das Problem ist dass einfach die
ukrainische Bevölkerung sehr viel
kleiner ist als die russische
Bevölkerung und deswegen absehbar auf
dem Schlachtfeld und es es sterben ja
unglaublich viele junge Männer dort das
oder werden verkrüppelt werden verletzt
das ist ja grauenvoll was dort jeden Tag
stattfindet wir sehen die Bilder nicht
aber wenn man sich ein bisschen
erkundigt kann man sich das im Groben
vorstellen und wie lange soll dieses
Gemetzel dieses Schlachten das ist
wirklich wie erster Weltkrieg also da
bewegt sich ja nichts also die die
Offensive ist ja gescheitert also das
die Front bewegt sich fast nicht mehr es
wird nicht gesiegt es wird nur noch
gestorben und dass Russland durchaus
bereit wä zu verhandeln das hat ja jetzt
kürzlich sogar noch mal der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der selenski Partei
der damals in Istanbul verhandelt hat
also es gab ja Verhandlungen in Istanbul
direkt am Anfang des Krieges und dieser
Fraktionsvorsitzende der selenski Partei
war der Chefunterhändler der Ukraine und
der hat jetzt in einem Interview gesagt
ganz öffentlich im ukrainischen
Fernsehen ja also die Russen hätten
damals den Krieg beendet wenn wir uns
verpflichtet hätten auf eine
natoperspektive zu verzichten und er war
noch ganz stolz darauf dass sie das
nicht gemacht haben sondern sich
entschieden hätten weiterzukämpfen ich
frage mich wie also sag mal die Frauen
die Kinder die jetzt ihren Vater ihren
ihren ihren Ehemann verloren haben also
ob die wirklich davon ausgehen dass es
das wert war für die natoperspektive auf
diesem Schlachtfeld zu sterben also ich
finde es ist ganz dringend damals glaube
ich wäre sogar noch ein wirklich guter
Friedensschluss möglich gewesen bei dem
die Russen sich zurückgezogen hätten ob
das jetzt noch geht weiß ich nicht aber
was ich über fest überzeugt bin sobald
also alles was verhandeln verhandeln ist
immer besser als schießen also das ist
ja nur der alte Spruch von hermut
Schmidt und es stimmt auch wir sollten
finde ich als westliche Staaten jetzt
Russland quasi anbieten oder vorschlagen
dass die Waffenlieferungen stoppen wenn
Russland sofort einem Waffenstillstand
zustimmt und dann würden die Waffen
schon mal schweigen und alle strittigen
Fragen müsste man versuchen auf dem
Verhandlungsweg zu zu lösen natürlich
hilft es dabei nicht wenn dann z.B in
der Ukraine ja per Dekret Verhandlungen
verboten sind also das ist ja zurzeit so
also ich finde schon dass wir ja auch
einen gewissen Druck aufmachen müssen
auch auf die ukrainische Führung und wir
könnten China nutzen um auch auf die
russische Führung Druck auszuüben dass
beide verhandlungsbereit sind und dass
es dann Gespräche gibt und was ich dem
besten auch der deutschen Regierung
vorwerfe ist dass man das gar nicht
versucht sondern dass gerade auch die
Bundesregierung mit einer Blindheit
sondergleichen immer nur sagt wir
liefern mehr und wenn die USA wenn den
wird das ja langsam zu teuer wenn die
sich zurückziehen dann liefert
Deutschland noch mehr man hat ja jetzt
gesagt man kann dafür die Schuldenbremse
aussetzen also für unser Bildungssystem
und unsere Investition will man die
Schuldenbremse nicht aussetzen aber für
Ukraine Waffen die wir dann vielleicht
liefern müssen weil die USA ist nicht
mehr macht dafür würde man das machen
mit der Begründung dass auch unsere
Werte dort verteidigt werden müssen und
das westliche Werte wie Freiheit und
Unabhängigkeit natürlich auch in der
Ukraine verteidigt werden gegen diesen
Aggressor der dieses Land angegriffen
hat ja wir haben auch mal irgendwann die
Freiheit Deutschlands am hindokusch
verteidigt und wir wissen wie es
ausgegangen ist ich halte von diesen
Phrasen nichts sondern ich bin fest
überzeugt man kann diesen Krieg
sicherlich noch ein Jahr weiterführen
dann werden noch mal 100underttausende
junge Männer da ihr Leben geben müssen
auf beiden Seiten vielleicht auch mehr
als 100.000 die Front wird dann immer
noch so sein wie sie jetzt ist also die
Frage ist ja wie lange soll es noch
gehen am Ende wird sowieso verhandelt
werden müssen und die
Verhandlungsposition der Ukraine hat
sich eher verschlechtert sie ist nicht
besser geworden also es wäre besser
gewesen im Frühjahr schon zu beenden
dann wäre wahrscheinlich also einfach
könnten viele Menschen noch leben und
das Land könnte schon wieder aufgebaut
werden jetzt wird immer noch zerstört es
wird immer noch gestorben ich halte das
für unverantwortlich wir sind schon am
Ende des Gesprächs haben nicht mehr viel
Zeit Frau wagenkncht lassen Sie uns das
nicht so düster beenden was läuft denn
richtig gut in Deutschland in ihrer
Meinung also ich finde gut dass viele
Menschen sich inzwischen auch eine
eigene Meinung bilden dass es auch
wirklich ja das sag mal viele auch sagen
so kann es nicht weitergehen wir
brauchen einen politischen Neuanfang und
darauf hoffe ich auch im nächsten Jahr
dass wir wirklich auch bei den Wahlen
sehen werden die Menschen wollen diese
jetzige Politik nicht aber sie wollen
auch keine unseriösen Konzepte sondern
sie wollen tatsächlich dass es wieder
aufwärts geht mit unserem Land und ich
muss sagen für mich ist wirklich Röhren
wenn ich mit oft auf der Straße mit ganz
einfachen Menschen spreche wie ja wie
wie engagiert sie sind wie wie viele mir
jetzt auch sagen wir wollen auch was tun
wir wollen uns auch bringen wir wollen
uns auch politisch engagieren wir haben
noch nie mit einer Partei zu tun gehabt
aber jetzt ist die Zeit das zu tun und
das macht wirklich ganz viel Mut das ist
noch viel Theorie das nächste Jahr wird
die Praxis zeigen auch für Sie Frau
Wagenknecht herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch
[Musik]
gerne